[Musique]
fou
le comité d'urgence s'est réuni pour la 15ème
fois et m'a recommandé de
déclarer la fin de l'urgence de santé publique
de
portée internationale. J'ai accepté cet
avis, c'est donc avec grand espoir
que je déclare la fin du covid-19 comme  une urgence sanitaire mondiale
Dieu sauve le roi Dieu sauve le
[Musique]
Roi
pour [
Musique]
go [
ils [
Musique]
pas [
fr
[Musique]
pour
ouais
[Musique]
[  Musique]
quand nous avons finalement conclu un accord, j'ai
un
mot, c'est vraiment quelque chose qui, euh,
c'est bien plus. Je crois qu'un livre entier
est une rampe de lancement pour les
startups européennes et aussi les chercheurs pour mener
la course mondiale pour ce que nos
concitoyens  je veux que la confiance soit méfiante
[Musique]
IA